[Applaudissements]
justement se rendre tout de suite aux
etats-unis puisque dans le 20 heures de
france 2 on a appris que les enseignants
de floride allez désormais pouvoir être
armé en classe une loi extrêmement
controversé et dont l'efficacité reste à
prouver regarde jusqu'ici plusieurs
comtés américains comme ce lycée rural
du colorado où la station de police et à
20 minutes de route autorisait déjà
certains enseignants à porter des armes
un pas supplémentaire a été franchi avec
la généralisation dans un grand état la
floride après la tuerie de parkland l'an
dernier où dix sept lycéens et
professeurs avaient trouvé la mort
de nombreux parents et élèves américains
soutiennent ce type de mesures les
enseignants qui souhaitent avoir une
arme en case devront suivre une
formation au tir de ce type
ouais on s'est fait à l'idée qu'on devra
tirer sur un enfant car je n'hésiterai
pas je n'y réfléchirai pas d'avoir 5
points selon un sondage 78% des
professeurs américains sont contre le
port d'armes à l'école des syndicats
d'enseignants de floride devrait déposer
plusieurs recours juridiques contre la
nouvelle loi alors pour eau potable tout
à fait dans l'actualité sachez qu'il ya
eu une fusillade qui a eu lieu il ya
deux jours dans un lycée diamond ranch
dans le colorado qui cette fusillade a
fait un mort et plusieurs blessés dont
plusieurs dans un état critique
deux suspects des jeunes étudiants ont
été arrêtés
donc évidemment c'est un vrai problème
un vrai fait de société aux états unis
pour autant que pensez vous de cette
proposition donc d'armes et les
professeurs dans leurs salles de classe
il y aurait une formation aux tirs nous
dit on qu'est ce que vous en pensez
christophe mais il faudrait déjà qu'ils
commencent par désarmer tout le monde
les unit voilà au lieu d'armer les
professeurs en fait vous savez que ce
truc là ça arrive parce qu'il ya une
belle contre toute attente une baisse
des ventes aux états les armes
oui voilà et là est la nra l'association
des détenteurs d'armes à feu a perdu
chrétiens de saint ours en est très très
puissante a perdu 15% et ils ont pas ils
ont fait passer un une loi enfin ils ont
fait passer un truc quoi comme quoi les
armes il serait interdit de transforme
une arme semi automatique en armes
automatiques de manière à ce que les
gens qui volent des armes automatiques
puissent en acheter
il relancer la vente des armes
automatiques donc si vous laissez il
marche sur la tête
c'est avant tout une mauvaise mais c'est
une
à quel moment à quel moment d'armer des
gens ça va calmer le jeu alors j'ai
l'impression que à côté de vous amélie
n'est pas d'accord non malgré moi je
pense que effectivement en france
oui on va pas se mentir c'est bizarre
c'est choquant parce qu'on n'est pas du
tout habitués moi même sommes très très
bizarre d'amener mon fils à l'école
édouard sa maîtresse armés c'est
évidemment voilà mais faut se mettre
aussi dans un contexte aux états unis où
il ya quand même des fusillades qui sont
devenues une routine dans certains cas
on sait que pour le processeur arm et
valbarelle cochard un moment donné je
pense que aussi qu'ils sont obligés
d'agir en fonction de ce qui se passe
c'est à dire que si peut-être que
certains professeurs avaient été armés à
certaines choses diadao au moment de
certaines cuisines
peut-être qu'ils auraient peut-être des
choses on aurait pu sauver la vie du
village supplémentaire mais je peux être
aussi qu'ils auraient pu se sauver la
vie ou sauver la vie de certains enfants
et de certains élèves qui a fait leur
avoue glace pas laissant tout de même
lorsque on entend ce professeur qui par
ailleurs est le directeur de l'école qui
dit oui je me suis fait à l'idée que je
fais j'ai devait peut-être je livrais
peu je pense oui mais il ne voit pas un
enfant il se dit je vais certainement
devoir tirer sur quelqu'un qui a envie
de me retirer la vie et de retirer la
vie de mes élèves
caroline mais chacun sa place c'est
aussi simple que ça les profs pour
enseigner les policiers pour maintenir
la le maintien ne se ferait par des
policiers dans le droit d'établissement
mais bien sûr moi je serais pas choqué
que ye devant les établissements et je
parle même de la france ou devant
certains lycées devant certains
établissements
des policiers dont c'est le métier de
maintenir la paix de maintenir l'ordre
qu'ils soient armés ils ont un sang
froid ils sont capables de maîtriser des
situations ce qui est quasiment est
complètement impossible dans le cas d'un
d'un professeur qui m'est absolument par
là pour ça et qui va le faire qu'empirer
les choses
et pardon effectivement on s'est fait à
l'idée de but et les gosses temps mais
83% d'aidé
des parents d'élèves aux états unis sont
d'accord avec l'idée d'un de policiers à
l'intérieur des établissements de
policiers armés
oui looking et de tvq en même temps
pardon mais quel système ça veut dire
qu'on est d'accord pour qu'il y ait des
policiers dans les établissements on est
d'accord pour qu'il y ait des
professeurs armés donc c'est une fine
bruine il a été amené des enfants dans
un lieu qui est censé être un lieu
d'apprentissage et que tout le monde
soit armé ça dépasse l'entendement mais
arrêtons de sortir uniquement les
petites phrases parce que cet homme où
il a dit ça je pourrais tirer sur un
enfant mais ça c'est réducteur c'est
bien sûr s'ils iront cas d'autodéfense
et qu'on est en train lui tirer dessus
donc là c'est facile de dire ça
premièrement et deuxièmement c'est
inimaginable côté français de penser
qu'on va armer en effet les professeurs
mais là il ya quand même un engrenage
aux états unis il faut bien se mettre à
leur place là bas on est n'est pas en
france là on est là bas où ils sont tous
armés on peut pas les désarmer comme ça
en claquant des doigts
il ya plein de gens qui ont des armes
chez eux donc c'est un fait la solution
de la sélection c'est désormais une
formation 144 heures pour les
professeurs donc c'est beaucoup c'est
peut-être plus que certains de nos
policiers d'ailleurs en france et
ensuite c'est peut-être une forme de
dissuasion qui peut être temporaire on
peut peut-être pensez-vous vraiment que
si de l'anc en l'occurrence par exemple
sur cette fusillade qui a eu lieu dans
le colorado
ces deux jeunes étudiants qui donc ont
forcément un pet au casque un pardon de
fait le fait de savoir que le professeur
est armé ça va les empêcher d'aller d'en
faire une tuerie de masse dans les
lycées ou psychologiquement ça peut
quand même changer les choses en effet
mis mais on est deux côtés soir mais bon
il a maintenant pignon le gac un pet au
cassis va arriver avec son arme
automatique pour faire un carton dans le
lycée il a pas dans l'idée de se faire
buter par un prof
il se dit qu'il va buter le prof avant
évidemment donc ça va pas du tout le
dissuader au contraire ça va même lui
mettre un challenge en plus
bon écoute et dites nous ce que vous en
pensez c'est vrai que c'est un vrai
c'est une vraie question c'est un vrai
sujet on a aussi parce que là on parle
des états unis mais il ya eu des
des questions aussi en france 2 doit-on
mettre des policiers dans des lycées
sont délaissés dits sensibles à l'entrée
de l'établissement des portiques
peut-être pour les armes à feu et autres
donc c'est une vraie question qui peut
évidemment de venir chez nous les
professeurs formés aux usa pour faire
face aux tueries est ce que vous êtes
pour ou est-ce que vous êtes contre
c'est assez partagés tout de même un
contrat 58% salle emporte tout de même
mais pour à 40 2 % voient que c'est une
vraie question c'est un vrai débat
alors il ya des ya des profs qui ont
déjà du mal avec juste leur bureau donc
regarder
[Applaudissements]